I'll say congratulations for the time being You
're quick to appear in the second bout and fight me
You're the 6th ship and I'm the original
at bat  That's because you're not serious about it,
which one
is better, cradle or bean bag
?  ]
You've been like that for a long
time You've mastered the skills I've learned over time But
you still have some spare
strength Do you know how miserable it is for
me So what I show with my arms is us  Who is the strongest dish of the 91st class?
It's burning me
over there Ah ah
Cup yakisoba, then let's finish it off
Each song has 8
zurbans The flavor of the product has all been ruined
You'll end here
The first match was a makeshift quirk
Consciousness  If I could smash the machine that is approaching you,
yeah